[Musique]
le fleuve baigné de lumière s'écoule
majestueux à Châteauneuf-sur-Loire il y
a trois siècles une multitude de bateaux
s'y croisaient en provenance de l'amont
et de Laval de la Loire entre octobre et
mars quand le tyrando était suffisant le
port long de 400 mètres fourmille est
alors de Marignier
il y avait énormément d'activités
puisque vous avez trois types de ports
vous avez le port commercial vous avez
le port au bac pour la traversée du
fleuve et puis un port refuge un peu
plus loin qui permettait au bateau de se
réfugier dans un à l'embouchure de la
monnaie qui est une qui est une rivière
et on pouvait mettre 50 80 bateaux à
l'intérieur
les gabars les tous les fut trop
acheminaient des matériaux de
construction depuis l'Allier et des
denrées alimentaires depuis
Saint-Nazaire via le port d'Orléans
dans la moitié du 18e siècle l'essor
d'un condiment va profiter à l'activité
portuaire de Châteauneuf
à partir de 1747 on va avoir un grenier
à sel à Châteauneuf ce qui fait que
effectivement des trains de bateaux
contenant du sel vont pouvoir remonter
jusqu'à Châteauneuf pour livrer ce sel
inquiétude denrée extrêmement précieuse
et nécessaire pour la conservation des
aliments à quelques centaines de mètres
du port le musée de la Marine de Loire
conserve les vestiges de cette époque
révoluent des objets qui accompagnaient
souvent les mariniers tout au long de
leur vie ces coffres en fait étaient
utilisées par les mariniers à bord des
bateaux lors de leur voyage
ils y mettaient des outils tout ce qui
est leur être nécessaire pour travailler
à abord réparé par exemple une petite
voix d'eau réparer une futaille un
tonneau qui fuit par exemple mais aussi
ils mettent quelques affaires
personnelles un peu de vêtements quand
ils en avaient
les hommes voguent sur la Loire depuis
des temps immémoriaux ces pièces de
monnaie attestent de la navigation sur
le fleuve au deuxième siècle après
Jésus-Christ
ces pièces effectivement qui ont pu être
qui ont été trouvés par un archéologue à
amateur lors d'une prospection au bord
de Loire et donc on a un amas de pièces
qui sont soudés entre elles par la
corrosion et dont l'amour seulement en
fait elles sont empilées les 1 sur les
autres là ça pensait qu'elles étaient
enfermées dans une bourse alors là le
cœur de la Bourse a disparu bien entendu
il est resté que le métal des pièces on
a pu voir une figure qui s'est très vite
érodée à l'air libre effectivement mais
ce sont des pièces qui semblerait du
début de leur chrétienne
sur la Loire capricieuse au fond de
sable mouvants il est arrivé que les
chalands fassent naufrage avec leur
blocs de pierre
ils ont été retrouvés par hasard comme
souvent par une entreprise qui est
extrayée du sable en fait de du lit la
Loire on a découvert que ces pierres
provenaient en fait de la carrière
d'Apremont sur Lallier donc en amont de
Châteauneuf et qu'elles étaient
destinées à Chantilly en aval la
cathédrale d'Orléans
Châteauneuf-sur-Loire fut le cinquième
port ligérien derrière Nantes tours
Orléans et Angers le développement des
routes et l'avènement du chemin de fer
mirent un terme à la Marine de Loire les
bateliers se firent pas seul ou bien
pécheurs
l'académicien Maurice genevois et
enfants du pays leur rend hommage dans
son livre des routes de l'aventure ainsi
il les vit entrer au Panthéon de
l'histoire